thanks for joining us America and Dave
Ramsey your host I am doing my best to
help your wealth be unequal I want you
to be part of the problem with wealth
inequality I want to make you wealthy I
want to show you how to handle money so
you can become vastly wealthy completely
change your family tree and give money
and help others like nobody's business
I want you to be the problem when people
are griping about wealth inequality I
want to see your face
that's my goal I'm trying to help you
get there I want you to be unequal I
want you to be better than average I
don't want you to be typical I don't
want you to be normal
listen I'm a member of the marriage in
equality movement too because I've been
married now for 30 almost 33 years which
makes me weird because very few people
have been and so my marriage is unequal
I'm a member of the kid inequality
movement to all three of my kids are
grown functional and don't live in my
house that's a bomb a member of the kid
inequality movement I don't want my kids
to be I don't want them to be normal I
don't want to be typical I want you to
be excellent I want you to be passionate
I want you to win I want you to do
things better than you've ever done them
before and you know the sad thing about
that is people who won't make the same
choices you make won't be in the same
position you're in after you do those
things after you make better choices
you'll start winning someone who plays
the guitar better than someone else
because they practice 10,000 hours more
than they practice makes more money
playing the guitar people who are more
talented putting a puck in the net do it
make more money playing hockey than
those who don't
that's why Wayne Gretzky made more money
than that other guy that you don't know
his name it's in it's it's not equal and
see somewhere along the line we taught
everybody that everybody gets a trophy
and then equal Izzie
that equal means fair fair is not equal
it would be unfair for you to get paid
the same amount of money to play a
guitar that Brad Paisley gets paid it
would be unfair for you to get paid the
same amount of money to play golf that
Tiger Woods gets paid because he's
better at it than you are so it would be
unfair for it to be equal instead of
equally as fair as a matter of fact
unequal is more fair than equal all now
I'm messing and tripping with your
little psychology in your little
philosophy or not equal is unfair how's
that smoke on it for a second equal is
unfair because people don't have equal
levels of effort if you go into the
classroom and kid doesn't do his
homework and another kid does his
homework a kid makes an F on the test
and another kid makes an a on the test
and at the end of the class everybody
gets an A how is that fair it was a
different level of effort oh yes there
was a different level of innate born DNA
intelligence - I wasn't blessed with
that when I had to just outwork the
smart kids but I never once whined about
them being smarter than me I mean I I
know lots of people that didn't even
have to go to class and they could just
make age me I'm in there just working my
little blue-collar butt off to get a
dad-blame B and that was on a good day I
mean I'm the half the class that allowed
the upper half to happen so I get it but
it would be unfair for everyone to get
an A and so be unfair for your income to
be equal deeply unfair
so you hadn't thought about that but the
problem is we have a kid
with 150 dollar highlights in his hair
living in his mother's basement sitting
in hundred-dollar skinny jeans typing on
a $3,500 MacBook Air that wealth
inequality is unfair and those are the
thought leaders in our culture now god
help us equal is unfair because the same
amount of talent the same amount of
effort the same amount of diligence the
same number of hours of labor we're not
put in and so here's the thing and then
we have to dream up the corporate
boogeyman and say well it's corporate
America its corporate America its
corporate corporate America has all
these unfair advantages well I sometimes
sometimes not but how has that kept you
from winning all of those people existed
the whole time I was building my life
and I became a millionaire by the time I
was 26 years old I was so stupid I lost
it all and I had to start completely
over and so I've done it twice while all
of those people were out there being
corporate America what are you doing
how does corporate America being
corporate America taken away your
opportunity your future you surrendered
it to a mythical boogeyman and sat on it
sat down on your button whined about it
and blamed it on this general general
thing it's the economy what's the
economy the economy is when you get up
and go make some money that's when your
economy starts it's a mythical boogeyman
I've met salespeople listen I got my
real estate license when I turned 18
years old I'm selling real estate debt
during Jimmy Carter interest rates were
17% fixed-rate to buy a home I'm 21
years old and I'm selling houses I sold
houses to people bought them at 17%
fixed rate from a 21 year old meanwhile
old goobers sitting in my office
on the end of a donut making zero
talking about how the economy is bad cuz
they're not working and I was so dumb I
just went out there and wandered around
and made knocked on doors and talk to
people and anything that popped up that
looked like it might be a real estate
deal I'm in their face digging and
scratching and clawing and I was awful I
was so green and so raw and so rude
walking around in my disco clothes at 21
years old trying to sell a house in 17%
interest rate and I still out sold
people sucking on the end of a donut
whining and believing it was the economy
because they had this mythical boogeyman
the economy the economy the economy is
17 percent interest rates sucked yes
they do they're horrible it was the only
environment I was sitting in and I still
had to make enough money to get through
school and so I didn't have a choice I
had to do something in this mythical
economy that had me down the boogie man
was holding me back and yet he didn't
work for a wonderful guy at the time who
had those classic sayings that you can
only find in the hills of East Tennessee
he said Rams are you're amazing he said
you're proof that even a blind hog can
find an acre now I'm not sure that was a
compliment I have to stop and I guess he
meant I worked hard and hard enough that
I could outwork all of my supposed
shortcomings during the economy the
economy the economy the economy the
economy the economy it's the economy
listen my whole life I've heard people
say it's the economy my whole life I've
heard people say they can't get ahead
because of corporate America and my
whole life I've watched people go win
during those times is it easy
no crap if it was easy we wouldn't
admire successful people but we've
gotten to where we worship socialism to
the point that we say wealth inequality
wealth inequality it's not fair it's not
fair it's not fair the economy is bad
the game is fixed you know I went got
this student loan debt and got a degree
in German polka history and now I can't
get a job and somebody lied to me
somewhere yeah they did so now what you
gonna do about it
it surrounds suck your thumb and wine
car I'm so sick of this this is the
greatest country in the world has ever
known when you spell America backwards
that spells opportunity and yet we're
teaching a whole generation to wait on
the government to fix their life
everybody gets a trophy it's got to stop
you guys opportunity is right there in
front of you it's only it's dressed like
work clothes though
dressed in overalls it's got a hammer in
the sling man you got to go move your
butt around to get things to happen it's
how it works out here in the real world
you